alright so this chapter starts out by by
talking a little bit in Congress Lee
about me at Turner then you remember
from your history classes who nat turner
was or why why he mattered why he was
important he was pre Civil War Dalton
anybody let slave rebellion after he led
his rebellion they really cracked down
and coats became more pressing her out
of Americans yet Turner was also a
preacher and he preached a sort of
apocalyptic type of full Christianity
that was part of his rebellion Turner is
is seen by many as being sort of a
founding figure or an ablum for a
particular approach to dealing with
racism doing the segregation during the
slavery dealing with all that legacy
that's why the book places him first in
here and then the book starts talking
about Cyprus ISM and it's going to spend
a little bit of time going over over
that we talked about separatism what we
mean in terms of ethnic separatism is
put aside african-americans stuff and
just think in terms of some of the
separatist movements going on today what
do they always want and it's in the word
what are their names
you know the globe has changed since you
guys are kids there's new cultures that
didn't exist when you were in elementary
oftentimes coming from separatist
movements what are they what do they
want yeah it's their own identity well
they usually think they've got their own
the devil what else can I be
acknowledged as such yeah okay so they
want their own land their own country
their own institutions and sometimes
will be worked up within a larger
society so separatism could be living in
a particular place in America but not
actually trying to have your own nation
it's very tough to get nation status in
America ever since the Civil War they
don't go for that sort of thing or it
might be actually trying to say well you
know people of this group need to be in
a completely separate place and
separatism took different forms like
that I mean there have been in the 1970s
there were calls to like set aside six
states for for african-americans and you
know all the way she relocated of those
states and all the african-american
should locate in those states that was
part of the black separatism in the
1970s totally unworkable proposition but
it gives you an idea of what was going
on one of the separatist ideas was the
back to Africa refrain and sometimes
this was by racist whites who are saying
you know we should set the former slaves
back in Africa get them out of the South
that won't that will take care of all
the racial problems sometimes it was on
the part of blacks themselves you know
for instance those who went back to
Liberia and founded a country there
which had its own problems afterwards
led to the caste system moving there
natives there what would be opposed to
separatism the book doesn't really do a
good job of bringing up this this
contrast somebody like Marcus Garvey
would be a hardware separatist yeah
unification well the unification was
like everybody is saying so we did a
unification thing everybody should be a
college professor like me study
philosophy that's not going to work
what's what's in between notification
and everybody's got to go their separate
ways okay the word that usually gets
used is integration but cohesive pneus
is a good word to use as well
integration having an integrated society
means that you have members if we're
thinking in terms of race it would be
all the different races are able to be
represented people can move from place
to place without fear that their racial
identities and used against them doesn't
have to be like you know the proverbial
Bennett on and where there's a better
system than you have to have you know
like one person of each race represented
in every single place matter of fact
College brochures often it made fun it
for that reason to because they often
try to do that sort of thing but the
idea is that that it's not that race
with the banner at all but it wouldn't
be an impediment it wouldn't be
something that wouldn't allow people to
hold things against each other that is
that's a goal so these are two different
goals these are two different responses
to the problem of originally slavery
the core that this is based out of
racism given the notion that there are
indeed completely separate races rather
than a human race is an expression of
racism in that respect so who would be
an example of somebody that you end up
would be for integration rather than
separate think about you know black
history yeah yeah he would be a great
example of that and if you wanted to
oppose somebody else around the same
time maybe Malcolm X you know this is a
traditional way yeah this is a esic
thing you can give the undergraduate
stuff right discuss the difference
between integration and separatism
Malcolm X it later on the putative as
we're going to see so we've got a lot of
different things going on why are we
talking about new urban religions
because this really doesn't become a
major factor until the mass migrations
from the American self up to the
northern cities of African Americans who
are getting out itself because frankly
the south is underdeveloped at that time
a shot through and through with
segregation and racism and we thought
they had a lot better prospects in the
northern cities so they move up to
Chicago Detroit New York Boston all
across this is northern tier and your
book talks first about Marcus Garvey so
Marcus Garvey he would be in the
separatists side he establishes
universal Negro Improvement Association
and the head of their aim the creation
of his entirely black society and
culture that would ban in the New World
and restore American blacks to their
ancestral home in Africa and so what
Garvey did is created like an entire
ideology like your book talks about a
broad network of symbols and
organizations and there were some
examples of how this got incorporated
with the African Orthodox Church Garvey
himself is not successful but Garvey
gets a lot of things rolling his ideas
are taking on shaping these other
thinkers then your book talks about some
other figures that don't quite fit in so
well with the thing having to do with
race so much but they're coming out of
these these northern cities and your
book talks about father divine father
divine was this founder of a peace
mission movement in New York and if you
want to place him in dispatch review of
the integrationist he preached racial
and overcoming of racial divisions he
had both black and white followers a lot
of his followers were actually women who
had been experimenting with other
religious movements yeah quite a few
people thought that he was you know so
God on earth they didn't have an awful
lot of theology the movement after he
dies doesn't have a lot of emphasis and
it's it's you know gradually diagonal
another guy that they talk about it is
Charles Emmanuel grace called so sweet
daddy grace who starts the United house
of prayer for all people he attracts a
lot of followers from the the sanctified
holiness and Pentecostal churches and
part of what he's particularly known for
is making claims about products he had
an entire line of soap magazines cold
cream toothpaste all these sort of
things we're supposed to climb as a
person spiritually and again charismatic
figure oftentimes once the main figure
is gone the organization doesn't do so
well and they're sort of languishing
along at this time so that's talking
about through
some early stuff and then some more or
less within the Christian line kind of
stuff if we want to think about black
nationalism a black separatism we also
want to talk in terms of Islam
interestingly enough when we're talking
about african-american Islam we have to
think in terms of and we'll talk more
about what this means later Sunni Islam
for his mainstream Islam is practiced in
most you know the countries where as
long as a major factor from Indonesia
all the way over to to Morocco or we can
talk and turns black Islamic we have to
go one of two ways and this is one of
the dilemmas for African American
Muslims the black Islamic movements that
are going to come about until there's a
lot of Islamic immigration really are
the big face of Islam within the United
States but to the main stream Islamic
world they're considered to be heterodox
that means they're not considered to be
genuinely Muslim they're considered to
have done some strange deviations to go
on their own way usually individuals
having committed shirt or having sent
something else God other than just just
a lot so there's kind of a dilemma here
this is something actually that I saw
when I was working in any
Prison it's also something that Malcolm
X himself had a deal with Sonia Islam is
multicultural in the sense that it spans
races it's that multicultural the sense
that we associate applying
multiculturalism saying anything though
is everybody's culture is just as good
as they don't think that the spans races
nations eras you can't effectively be a
racist within the American setting can
be a Sunni Muslim if you really take
some Islam seriously because to belong
to it it's certainly you know belonging
to the Catholic Church to belong to the
Catholic Church means belonging to a
church that includes people of ever seen
race coming from everywhere and Sunni
Islam is really like that they're their
concerts and long-standing you know
generational members from every single
race you can think of these days so if
you want to be a separatist and say that
somehow you know the African Americans
should be totally separate because you
know racism because the better or
something like that you're not going to
be able to be a sunny was it was why
Malcolm X abandons his view on race
because it becomes a swing muzzle on the
black Islamic movements would be things
like the boorish science or the nation
of islam or offshoots like a five
percent nation
five percenters flush it nation of gods
there's a lot of different different
lawsuits of these all of them have in
common taking some things from
traditional Islam but adding some things
to it so for example the more of science
temple which is got a bit as guys drew
Ali they thought that blacks were really
Asians and therefore Moors for Muslims
so there's this entire sort of backstory
having to do with where we're a race
came from for from these the Nation of
Islam you're going to get this this
whole story about blacks being the
original people whites being created
there's a couple different versions of
this being created by an evil scientist
whites taking over and you know that
should it'll be a world in which it
that's that's taken care of it there are
no more whites and harmony again but
that's not traditional Islam it was a
matter of fact truly actually adds his
our bags to the to the Quran so the
moorish science temple Quran is not the
same thing as you're going to find them
a sunny Los the moorish science temple
is the one that gets things started
there they're not that successfully
after drew leaves in part because
there's a lot of in fighting over who
should actually be the successor this is
something that you see in charismatic
movements give a leader they bring about
a lot of new ideas and that after they
die or go off the scene there's always
this question about who should be in
charge who is the real successor to them
the Nation of Islam ends up largely
supplanting them as the dynamic force
within african-american communities yeah
that get started by this guy WD fard
Muhammad he establishes a temple and a
set of teachings activities institutions
in Detroit his his place is taken by
Elijah
and Elijah Muhammad leads the nation of
islam to sort of national prominence now
like in full points out Malcolm X plays
an important role in here he's a major
spokesperson for the Nation of Islam
until the he does something particularly
important for Muslims does anyone has
anybody ever read the autobiography of
malcolm x no big book when I was a kid
yeah very good yeah so this is something
we're going to talk a little bit more
about when we talk about Islam
particularly Sunni Islam in America one
thing Muslims are supposed to do if they
can if they have the resources during
their lifetime is go on a pilgrimage to
Mecca so Malcolm X goes on this
pilgrimage to Mecca and what does he see
when he is you know will observe these
crowds circling around the combine
they're all different races so he
realizes that Orthodox traditional Islam
is not going to allow for this racist
interpretation that he's got so he
converts the Sunni Islam and he ends up
getting you know getting shot that
doesn't go well for him there's there's
other things that take place as well
within the Nation of Islam Elijah
Muhammad's son Wallace deen mohammed
after after Elijah Muhammad dies when he
takes over he actually does a similar
cat shift and it changes the name to the
American Muslim mission the current
Nation of Islam that exists today is
really a splinter group from the innate
the original Nation of Islam and it's
louis farrakhan the driving member in
there now what do they actually stand
for what gives a nice summary of this it
says the nation can be understood as
systematically attempting to raise
American blacks of the social and
personal disorganization
Galloway particularly in the northern
cities and to instill instead a
collective sense of pride and
achievement through a puritanical II
disciplined lifestyle one thing that you
know you see the Nation of Islam members
you can count on them to be pretty
disciplined have a very strict code that
they're going to follow they rejected
traditional soul food I'll stimulants
and intoxicants in favor of of
nutritious regimen marital fidelity
collective ownership of small businesses
and farming enterprises and third going
and rejection and avoidance of white
society as possible so this is part of
the separatists idea separatism really
only works if you have some sort of
riding moral force behind it in the
nation of islam was able to do that in
recent years your book doesn't actually
talk about this much because it's fairly
recently the Nation of Islam as they
actually started incorporating some
practices from the term of psychology
including the you know using the book
Dianetics and doing some of the
practices that really has not gone over
well with traditional most times because
they you know they already thought the
Nation of Islam was pretty heterodox
that sort of captain for them the last
group that your book talks about I want
to throw it up on the board just to save
a little time are the Rastafarians what
are you guys associate Rastafarians with
or rastas there's the sort of mainstream
image right there so you know green
black and yellow right what else yeah
like Bob Marley and like dreadlocks and
fencing mm-hmm reggae music the
dreadlocks was originally primarily
around something like I caught on a lot
of people start doing it what else
anything else
yeah so you leave yeah the name ganja
comes from the Rastafarians and has a
sort of sacramental significance for
them the Rastafarian movement is
actually if you want to be very
technical about it fits within sort of
the black Jewish movements so it starts
in in Jamaica and you know we started
talking about Marcus Garvey Marcus
Garvey plays a role in this Marcus Ghana
guard he had a prophecy of the black
king would be proud in Africa in near
future near future so this actually
happens in Ethiopia which at that time
is one of the few independent African
nations all the rest of them at more or
less been colonized except for Liberia
and Rastafari mekonnen is crowned
emperor of ethiopia takes the name Holly
Celestine powered the Holy Trinity in
Ethiopian and so a lot of Jamaican
ministers start preaching the message
throughout the island they saw Silesia
is a messiah her for black people at
general sort of pan-african thing
throughout the Caribbean America Africa
and in descendant of King Solomon and
the Queen of Sheba so really what we've
got here is a variation on black Judaism
there's other variations on this as well
your book doesn't talk about liking the
Hebrew Israelite movements things like
that but you know again in order to save
time will not go into those